welcome to your round 4 recap of the  sink filled cup the strongest chess  tournament in history here in st. Louis  well it's all been fabulous fabiano  number two player in the world Caruana  blitz seem to feel with a perfect for no  start and today he crushed Levon Aronian  an amazing style here playing the move  rook to h5 and if LaVon had captured  than simply this beautiful sacrifice  capturing all his pieces and trapping  and night forcing LaVon to resign yeah I  didn't expect it at all I'm trying not  to get ahead of myself Fabiano's playing  he's playing proper chest you know I  have a great record against Fabiano's so  I just have to beat him basically that  sets up a key round 5 matchup between  tournament leader fabiano caruana and  hikaru nakamura be sure to join us here  in st. Louis for more coverage of the  sink filled cup at 150 central at us  chess champ calm